we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
we uh last week i told you joe biden's
approval rating is low
and some people actually became furious
with me because of that
this voicemail is a parody of those
people i'll tell you more about it in a
moment
hello this is alan from jersey i'm so
outraged at you david how dare you
report accurate information on joe
biden's approval rating we need you to
lie and distort exactly the same as fox
news does except on the left so when fox
news lies and distorts about trump you
need a lie and distort about biden you
can't admit the truth about his approval
ratings i'm so outraged at you telling
the truth that i've had to sign up for
10 to 15 memberships just so i can
cancel 10 to 15 memberships in
disapproval it's exactly like flushing a
toilet you need to do it 10 to 15 times
okay now this guy is joking but in all
seriousness i mentioned this on a stream
the other day i got emails after
reporting that joe biden's approval
rating is low now that's not my opinion
of joe biden and it's not my poll i'm
just report i've reported to people when
george w bush was president i would tell
you his approval and when obama was
president i would tell you his approval
and when trump was president i would
tell you his approval now i tell you joe
biden's approval which is low guys it's
low i'm not going to lie to you and i
had one person write in saying what
david uh
you're mad that biden hasn't given
everybody a pony like no that story
wasn't about my opinion that story was
what is his approval rating other people
saying i shouldn't be poisoning the well
by mentioning that his approval rating
is low what does that even mean
what are you talking about are you
saying i should hide information or lie
to the audience it's crazy and yes a
handful of people cancelled memberships
because i said hey guys joe biden's
approval rating isn't doing so well
this is what i'm talking about
the right spends a weekend funding a
glitzy event with pyrotechnics making
stars out of their lunatic politicians
coalescing activity and activism and and
energy and meanwhile over here like
david you mentioned biden's approval
rating i'm canceling my five dollar a
month membership it's concerning stuff
said it before it's very concerning
on today's bonus show by the way the
bonus show ron desantis is now going
around saying biden stimulus caused
inflation
so they should send the money to
floridians but it's like that won't
actually change the inflationary element
of it
a students in a dallas school district
are now going to be mandated to wear
clear backpacks in order to make it
evident if there are guns in the
backpacks that's where we are
and missouri democrats after video of
republican senator josh hawley was
released of him running out of the
capital on january 6th they are doing a
holland holly 5k race
sort of making fun of josh hawley we
will talk about that and more
on today's bonus show don't miss
tomorrow evening's town hall
6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific it will be
streaming live on pacman live
and everybody will be welcome to call in
through the discord at davidpakman.com
discord and yes
our website members will get priority
participation on the town hall you can
sign up at joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code big voting 22
to get a discount looking forward to
seeing everybody number one on today's
bonus show and number two uh during the
town hall event tomorrow see you then